ich bin in berlin auch in berlin aber
ich mein haus ist auch in bonn
und ich bleibe weiterhin in dieser
kreuznach in rheinland-pfalz leben und
wohnen und ja ich behalte den
landesvorsitz als cdu-vorsitzende und
die spitzenkandidatur die wird
entschieden wenn es soweit ist
na ja mit meinem 45 bin ich so mittel
frisch also insofern ist mit erneuerung
oder über alte glaube ich eher passen
die schubladen nicht ist sind neue
gesichter in der bundesregierung zum
zuge gekommen das glaube ich es gut mit
mit erfahrenen kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich glaube im zusammenspiel wird das
gut passen und nicht in einer revolution
und abräumen wäre die schon länger dabei
sind die gesellschaft verändert sich und
damit auch die fragen und auch die
aufgaben die an parteien gestellt werden
und parteien wenn sie eine relevanz in
der gesellschaft behalten wollen müssen
bereit sein sich auch zu erneuern und
sich den neuen frage stellen auch zu
stellen und das geht mit zb
programmdebatte einher wie eine grippe
kramp karrenbauers anstößt